hey there and welcome to pro flows
lesson 1.4 i'm cameron and today we are
talking about
lights and shadows in after effects in
3d
and let's go one step further now and
let's add some
some real dimension
to like we've been i've been showing you
how to add dimension with lights and
shadows but we're going to go even a
step further with some 3d dimension with
shadows and this is inspired by
a promo piece i saw online
um maybe on tv and then i found it
online um it was for called a show
called project blue book
and i thought it was really interesting
i found it um if you haven't seen a
promo for search project blue book it's
a
tv series i believe on tv where it was
on tv
um and they have an interesting end
title graphic i thought was pretty cool
so
i'm not gonna show you that here you can
google it if you want to project blue
book but uh i'll show you what i'm gonna
create here based on inspired by that so
we've got a background texture here and
i've made it
3d
and i've also got a cc toner effect
applied here which is just under effect
color correction cc toner
it's an effect i like to use a lot of
times
instead of tint because you can do
things like tent is just two colors
cc toner allows you to do duotone
tritone or pintone or a solid so i just
set it to a very simple blue color like
you see here
and then we're going to add some type
here so
actually what we're going to do before
we do that let's push this back just a
little bit in z space
just a little bit maybe something like
that so the edges are still off screen
but it's a little bit farther back i'm
going to add some type
and we're going to call this
project
shadow
and let's go ahead and let's make sure
that we are um centered here
we're in the center and let's go ahead
and change the typeface to
i believe it's called april
titling
yeah i think that's it i like that a lot
i'm just going for like an old school
kind of look here
and then we're going to make that 3d
and then we're going to also add
you don't have to do this but just add a
secondary
line like a subtitle um we'll do lights
and actually
lights
and
shadows
actually already used the word shadow so
let's do light
and
dark
and we're going to bring that one just
below here and let's decrease to half
the size so if we're 120 we're at 117 so
let's just say 120. half of that would
be 60.
so there it is
and i'm just going to position like that
and we've got two
3d layers here
and let's add a spotlight
oh not solid
layer new light
and let's make it a spot and let's make
it
a little bit off-white there
let's do 100 intensity
and let's do some fall off for this one
i don't know what
the radius is going to be yet
um but let's just add that
and i want to show you a trick here
which is
a lot of times people complain that's
hard to control
3d lights and after effects but i have a
trick that's pretty awesome to use
if you know how to do it so we're gonna
do is we're gonna add a new camera and
sometimes i get this switch so just bear
with me here so this camera has to be a
two node camera
and i believe so depth of field is
turned off i believe we can use about
any
preset
um i like to go with i think 28
depth field is off two node and i'll
tell you why two node has to be
the camera because
we're going to link these nodes and a
spotlight has two nodes it has a point
of interest and a position okay so we're
going to open up point of interest and
position
and we're going to open up the camera
but let's actually just call this
light
view
and
let's
open up the transform properties here
and what we want to do is we want to
tie the light
point of interest to the camera point of
interest in a light position to the
camera position and it's really easy to
do i'm not one for complex expressions
so all we're going to do is we're going
to alter option click
point of interest and we're just going
to pick whip up here to this point of
interest
and click outside
we're gonna do the same thing for
position we're gonna alter option click
here
pick whip up to the position here
click outside
now
we don't we don't see our light anymore
and that's because
we are we've attached our light to our
camera which you can see
right here okay
so um
now what's really cool about this is
this is our view here okay if i want to
position my camera or my light sorry all
i have to do
is look through my light here and it'll
position my camera so to make it a
little bit easier to understand
sometimes what i'll do is i'll add
another camera
so this camera we'll just call it
a main view
camera
and it doesn't have to be a two note
it's just a one note and this is just
the camera we're gonna look through okay
um and what it's gonna what's gonna
happen is here we're gonna on this view
here instead of active camera we're
going to change it right here to our
main view which nothing happens because
our main view camera and our light view
camera are in the same position which
you can see here so if i click here
there's our main view
and there's our light view okay now if i
move my light view up
now you can see here's the main view
still sitting here now this
composition is looking through the main
view
this composition we're going to set to
look through the light
okay so now we're looking through the
light over here
so if i am in this window
and i start positioning
my camera with see i'm on the camera
tool here the c
i can
move my spotlight you can see it
happening over here
with my camera okay
so we're just going to do a rough
position
somewhere right here for now just kind
of up above really close to the wall we
actually we're going to hit c we're
going to move in just a little bit
closer i want a pretty intense
light happening here okay
now
i can close up my light view i need to
increase my
my inverse falloff
under light options here we can close
the transform down
and we need to increase our falloff
distance
so
maybe we'll increase the radius and the
falloff distance
so let's just go ahead and increase this
way up there so we have
we can see our type here
and
you know i think fallout distance
doesn't seem to be doing much on this
one so we'll leave it right there shadow
darkness let's just turn it down just a
hair
and
diffusion i think is okay
yeah that works so now
we're not seeing any shadows here
because these
type uh chunks here aren't set to
project shadows so remember how we do
this we select both we hit a a and we're
gonna say cast shadows on
right now again there's nothing
happening here because our light is up
here um kind of shooting downwards if i
move if i go back to my light view and i
move it
here to the front you can see
there's our shadows over here right so
i'm moving down here kind of to the
front
which that's a pretty cool effect
but it's not the effect i'm going for
i'm going for like this kind of a long
shadow effect here so how am i going to
do that so here's a really cool trick
um what i'm going to do here is
save and you saw in previous lessons i
kept
being on the cinema 4d renderer and i
didn't want to be well now i want to be
on that renderer so i'm going to change
it to cinema 4d render
and i'm going to click ok it just says
enabled this is what works this is what
doesn't that's the thing about the
cinema 4d renderer certain things don't
work when you turn it on so you have to
be aware of that i've changed it to the
cinema 4d renderer immediately nothing
has changed right
the magic is here inside of our text so
i'm going to open up project shadow here
i'm going to go into my geometry options
and i'm going to say let's extrude this
text so you can see what's happening
here it's extruding outwards
and i'm just going to stretch it way
back
here
you know so it's it's crossing through
this back plane
and now all of a sudden we're seeing
some shadow
projected down here right
i'm gonna go to the to um
light and chat light and dark do the
same thing here
geometry i'm gonna extrude this one out
as well
so it's cutting through there
yeah we've got some nice
shadows starting to
go down the sides here now we need to
change some some textures up here so
what i like to do is just pretty much go
into the the textures here and start
playing around i don't want to see
um a lot of the side colors here like
this white that's not what i want so i
need to play around with this a little
bit
so what i'm going to do here i'm going
to turn these all the way down
maybe turn the
yeah because you can see it by turning
up the specular intensity to 100 you can
see it a little bit better there
um let's see metal
um
[Music]
not necessary i'm gonna go up to project
shadow here
do the same thing turn ambient all the
way down diffuse all the way down
uh specular intensity up
shine is down
metal down ooh
okay there it's all different so metal
back to 100
yeah so when i turn off specular
intensity you can see it just goes
completely black here
and
don't want to fuse i don't want
anybody it's not going to do anything
metal
does nothing
i think that might possibly work
actually let's go ahead and just crank
this down and let's crank
this down to 60.
yeah so that looks a little bit better
so now what i want to do is i want to
really focus in on my light here and
just get it really kind of tuned in to
where i want it to be
so i'm just going to play around with
this
and i'm going to go into my intensity
again i'm going to use my wiggle
expression some alt option click
and go wiggle
and 20
50.
maybe i'll zoom in just a hair
and let's see how that
looks okay so my computer just crashed
uh after effects just crashed so i
rebuilt a few things here
uh
extrusion things like that reposition
the light
pretty close to where we left off so
this is where we're at so uh you can see
the camera's slightly i repositioned it
slightly different i think than where we
left off but that's okay
um i think we left off was the intensity
of the light so i want to create like
this
wiggle
effect with the light intensity so it's
like a flicker effect with this light i
love flickers with um lights and things
like that so
do that i'm also going to
turn down the cone angle
maybe like 65 i want it to be a pretty
tight maybe 60.
so we're starting to get some real mood
right here i'm also going to take down
the shadow diffusion way down
because i want it to be a much
harsher type of light there we go so you
can see here you can really get a lot of
definition if i turn it all the way off
it's too straight for me
but if i turn it up to like
10
it's just got a nice shadow there so i'm
going to save here so now we've got it
saved
now i want to um
well actually before we preview this i
also want to do just like a very simple
transition where the light kind of just
moves into place
um kind of quickly and so to do that to
animate the light all we have to do is
animate the camera because we're linked
the light point of interest and the
position is linked to the camera so
we're just going to animate the point of
interest
uh to end up
right where we're at but we want to
start with it
you know maybe
i'm just messing with the x here
maybe over in here
you know something like this where it's
just
you know just an edge of light right
there i do see that the background is a
little bit cut off so let's
actually let's make the camera
what's the camera we're pretty wide here
let's go to a 35 millimeter
and now we're pushing just a little bit
more and let's ease in keyframe
ease in here
so the light comes into position
[Music]
like so
i actually want to back my main camera
out
just a little bit
so we're not so tight there
and then i also want to give this point
of interest just a little bit of wiggle
as well so we'll say wiggle
and we're going to say one time every
second
but a high value here of like 700 so
it's gonna really kind of move around
and create some interesting
movement here um i also want to it looks
a little dark here but that's okay we're
just gonna play it back and see how it
looks i also want to change the color of
the text here it's right now it's a
straight up white
and i found that a yellowish color
did look okay but uh
maybe it wasn't the
bring up the ambient just here what does
that do not the ambient i think we're
gonna bring up the diffuse
yeah so bringing up the diffuse just a
little bit bring some color to this
which you can see a little bit here i
just i mainly just want to see it on the
front
so let's just try
an experiment here let's just make it
really yellow and see what it looks like
it does not look good
i solo it
yeah
tell you what let's just make the light
a little bit yellow so we'll go to layer
make sure our spotlight's selected layer
light settings and let's just make it
a little on the
yellow side just a little bit see that's
already too much
i like how that's looking it's just a
little too intense
maybe here
that's not too bad
i'm going to save
and let's preview this
so here's what it looks
like it's getting close now one thing
it's it's missing i don't love how much
it moves uh once it comes in here it
kind of it comes in and then it kind of
just it moves a little bit too much like
when it leaves the texture i want to
kind of stay in that area so i'm going
to turn down
the 700 value to maybe like
500. so it's not going to move quite as
much i'm also going to create a little
bit more intensity with the
actual light
amount so let's bump this up to 125
maybe even 150
something like that let's take the
radius
a little bit further out
let's also
i think it'd be interesting to have the
shadows
right now the point of interest is
moving so the shadows are there but if
the light if the base of the light was
moving which is the base of the camera
then it could create a little bit more
movement down in here
um it's hard to tell
like you can see here that the
i want to see these edges really move
right so right now the edges are pretty
much just there like uh the p here the
bottom of the p the bottom of the r
um it looks really nice
but they just kind of stay in place
right i want that shadow to move a
little bit more which means i probably
need to animate or add a wiggle
expression to the base of the light
which is the base
of the camera right
so let's do that so let's go back to our
light view
so we've got a wiggle expression on the
point of interest let's add one to the
position
wiggle
let's do 20
70.
and right when i enabled that you saw
the shadow move so if i turn this
expression off
see how the shadow goes back to where it
was
now it's moving which means it tells me
that we are affecting the actual
position the base of the light you can
see it here so now there's this very
subtle movement down in here
which looks really nice
like i said i was inspired by project 51
and on project 51 there's a camera move
and things like that that happen um but
i thought this was really interesting
how they created some tension some
mysteriousness with the base of the
shadow um with and to me it looked like
they did it in after effects with the
spotlight so
proof of concept is what this is
and
just to watch it through here
yeah see that's really interesting so
you could even do more with this you
could
make the light maybe go away at the end
to transition off you could animate the
camera to have the camera maybe have
some some shakiness to it some handheld
movement to it as well
that's going to make it a little bit
more interesting
[Music]
just talking about it makes me want to
do it
so maybe i will really quickly here
just to see so i'll do wiggle
i don't want a lot
of movement but i want it to happen so
maybe 20 pixels but i want it to happen
maybe quite a you know
so it's a little bit frenzied
you could also do something like i think
in the promo the camera starts on the
side of the text and then kind of zoom
pulls around to reveal the text as well
which was interesting interesting um
i didn't want to do that for this
example
yeah i mean that's a little bit too much
maybe it's like
an eight
you know less is more with motion
graphics motion design less is always
more it's the subtleties that sell it
and when you do go into cinema 4d
rendering like we are right now it does
slow down the machines a little bit
it slows down my machine i'm just
running an imac 5k at this point
um but it gets the job done
yeah so that's okay too i think it still
needs some some tweaking with the
movement i'd probably do like a push-in
or something like that and maybe i would
tweak the wiggle
amount a little bit as well but that's
going to do it for this lesson on
project shadow lesson 1.4
hopefully you learned something cool
[Music]
you